dans l'entreprise pommier l'horticulture
est une histoire de famille créée en
1926 par son arrière-grand-père c'est
maintenant Eugénie pommier quatre
générations après qui est en charge de
l'activité c'est une histoire de
transmission de savoir de père en fils
et de père en fille qui est
dans nos valeurs et dans
dans notre sang même peut-être je vais
dire depuis autant d'années maintenant
spécialisé dans les cactus et
succulentes l'entreprise est classée
première productrice française avec plus
de 500 000 plantes grasses produites par
an elle a également récemment obtenu le
label produit en Île-de-France une
fierté pour cette entreprise qui compte
une dizaine de salariés à l'année un
travail de longue haleine qu'on continue
tous les jours qui est pas évident
puisque on travaille en fait sans
machine donc on a que des des
collaborateurs qui travaillent avec nous
donc son optique main qui font tout ce
travail là c'est le temps quand il le
veut bien donc on on en dépend
énormément donc assez dur et puis on
utilise aucun produit phytosanitaire pas
d'engrais chimique que de l'engrais
naturel pas de tourbe la terre végétale
avec un mélange qui est notre recette
depuis la nuit des temps maintenant dans
cette entreprise entre 500 et 1000
variétés sont proposées seulement
destinés aux professionnels depuis sa
création elle s'est ouverte aux
particuliers depuis le 1er septembre
décidé d'ouvrir pas en construisant une
boutique mais en ouvrant nos cercles
donc notre outil de travail qui partage
quand ils viennent
la vie quotidienne de l'entreprise
comment on prépare une commande comme on
remporte comment on s'occupe des plantes
comment on fait de la production qu'on
puisse les renseigner qu'on puisse
échanger donc là je suis en train de
dépoter la plante de son pot de
production
et ensuite je vais la recommence la
rempoter dans son pot dans lequel il va
être vendu donc un pot en terre cuite je
retire toujours un petit peu de mode et
je mets un petit peu de terre fraîche au
fond
ça se passe bien la meuf je retire les
mauvaises herbes
et après on remet de la bonne terre
fraîche pour avoir quelque chose
d'esthétique et en même temps ça nourrit
la plante depuis quelques années c'est
assez tendance parce que ça cette
particularité d'être assez décoratif
puisqu'on va avoir plein de variétés
différentes plein de formes différentes
plein de couleurs différentes et une
seule et même variété ne sera jamais
pareil et on a derrière un entretien qui
est d'une simplicité sans nom puisqu'on
demande quand même très peu entre
guillemets d'attention sur ces plantes
là c'est la plante pour les nuls comme
comme le dit le bouquin
les serres sont ouvertes aux
particuliers du mercredi au samedi de 10
heures à 19 heures